-Welcome back, guys. It is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
And this week,
in honor of the big game,
I sent out the hashtag
#3WordSuperBowl
and I asked you to tweet out
a funny 3-word
Super Bowl prediction.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S. --
number one, actually.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number one, yeah.
So thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
3-word Super Bowl tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one
is from @MikeyMikeFace.
[ Light laughter ]
Mikey Mike Face.
-Mikey Mike Face.
-Yeah, he says...
Oh, interesting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's --
I do love the commercials.
[ Chuckles ]
This one's funny.
From @veldhouse jill,
she says...
-Oh!
-There you go. It is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Monday follows the Super Bowl.
-Oh, always. Always.
-This one's from @carolkach.
She says...
Oh, I didn't know that.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Is he?
-[ Chuckling ] God.
-This one's from
@DreamSymbols101.
She says...
Oh.
-Yeah!
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo, whoo, whoo, whoo!
Grease that pole!
-[ Laughs ]
This one's from @probogie67.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, that's true.
-Same length.
-Half of it.
-Yeah.
This one's from @MattPalmerV1.
He says...
That's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Either way, she wins.
This one's from @owleealeckza.
-Mm.
She says...
Well, that's true, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one's from
@KathleenHildeb8.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Yeah. I agree.
And this last one's
from @KyleDice23. He says...
There you have it, everybody.
[ Applause ]
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.